vsauce kevin here with a math problem or
a moral problem or both
in 1972 two men were convicted of
cashing fraudulent checks one for 58
dollars and 40 cents and the other for
dollars and 20 cents neither had a
criminal history one got 30 days the
other got 15 years
in the arizona versus marlow murder case
the defendant was sentenced to death and
his co-defendant who also participated
in the killing
got just four years
and a 2016 working paper from the
national bureau of economic research
showed that judges in louisiana gave
harsher sentences to juvenile offenders
on the mondays after the lsu tigers
football team
lost a game
what makes criminal sentencing
so unfair
at the most basic level justice is
giving people what they deserve part of
that might be punitive if you've harmed
someone else or society in general maybe
you deserve to be punished part might be
protection that society shouldn't be
exposed to continual threats of harm or
should sentences be purely about
restitution and rehabilitation with a
restorative focus on healing the victim
and improving the offender
if so should a criminal only serve as
much time as it takes to make sure it
won't happen ever again a just sentence
has to find a balance between all these
valid philosophical questions
and outcomes can vary tremendously from
judge to judge
tremendously
in 1973 the sentence in the united
states for a federal charge of
kidnapping was
any term of years to life you could get
probation or you could get 25 years
depending on the judge
federal judge marvin frankel called the
potential for sentencing disparities
unthinkable in a government of laws not
met
his book law without order exposed
shocking variations in federal
sentencing as a result of a complex
system in which hundreds of years of
ever-evolving law can determine your
guilt while a robed public official
who's in a bad mood because they've got
heartburn can make you pay whatever
price they want in that moment frankel
highlighted the almost wholly unchecked
and sweeping powers we give to judges in
the fashioning of sentences and he
called them terrifying and intolerable
for a society that professes devotion to
the rule of law
but the math-based cure
was worse than the disease of human
variability real quick this video is
sponsored by surf shark vpn look
everyone knows that vpns are great for
securing your devices while using public
wi-fi but you may want to consider using
it at home too surfshark encrypts your
online data masks your ip address and
their clean web feature blocks ads
trackers malware and phishing scams it
allows you to avoid those creepy
personalized ads like that anime body
pillow you were just curious about but
you're not actually going to buy
probably it can even change your virtual
location allowing you to stream content
blocked in your region and you can use
one account on an unlimited number of
devices there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee so there's no risk to try it
and i have a massive deal use code
vsauce2 to get 83 off and an extra three
months for free linked down in the
description below thanks to surfshark
for supporting vsauce2
okay here's the thing sentencing is hard
look let's try to solve sentencing for
property crime right now a judge
calculates the amount of labor it takes
the crime victim to get a thing and a
thief serves exactly that amount of time
as punishment for stealing it so let's
say you make twenty dollars an hour
someone steals your one thousand dollar
tv so they'd serve the 50 hours of labor
they took from you the sentence fits the
harm done in the crime and everyone's
sentence would be calculated without
prejudice that sounds perfectly fair
right wrong we've just incentivized
everyone to go steal elon musk's car
because your punishment would only be
the two minutes of labor it took him to
buy it every incarnation of justice has
unintended consequences
but you can eliminate statistical
outliers the sentencing reform act
passed in 1984 as a result of frankel's
advocacy for a fairer more consistent
justice system
and both republicans and democrats
supported its introduction of
objectivity
putting crimes through a complex
algorithm to determine sentences with
mandatory minimums and maximums that
lessened the impact of outright bias and
just plain philosophical disagreement
among judges
rehabilitation was abandoned simple
punishment was the goal
and what's more objective than numbers
and formulas
it worked like this a crime was assigned
one of 43 levels
so trespassing is level 4 kidnapping is
level 32 then levels could be added or
subtracted based on the specifics of a
crime a level 20 robbery would become a
level 25 if a firearm was brandished and
a level 27 if it was actually fired if
the offender was a lesser participant in
the crime four levels would be taken
away down to level 23 did they accept
responsibility two more levels gone one
level gone for pleading guilty back to
level 20. then that number was put into
a six category criminal history table to
calculate the range of sentencing for a
level 20 offense by someone with a
category 3 criminal history 41 to 51
months but even determining levels ended
up having problems in the 1991 case
chapman vs united states the court
decided that the medium in which a drug
was transmitted would count as the
weight of the drug being factored into a
dealer's sentence
the case involved lsd selling 100 doses
in sugar cubes came with a sentence of
188 to 235 months another dealer with
100 doses in paper
would get 63 to 78 months because paper
weighs so much less than sugar cubes 100
doses of pure unadulterated lsd with no
mixture only 10 to 16 months
one single dose of lsd in this gallon of
chalky milk would get me sentenced for
about 4 kilos of schedule 1 drugs and
serve over 20 years in prison as a first
time offender
[Music]
none of this makes any
sense
an appeals judge said to base punishment
on the weight of the carrier medium
makes about as much sense as basing
punishment on the weight of the
defendant
running crimes through rubrics and point
systems to determine arbitrary numerical
values divorced sentences from the
unique aspects of the crime and its
victims and the characteristics of the
offender
it also totally nullifies a judge's
lifetime of professional expertise
but mandatory federal sentencing
guidelines actually did solve problems
a study by the u.s sentencing commission
found that in 1986
sentences varied by about 17
and just seven years later that
variation was cut to 11 percent
mandated sentences cut down the
influence of judges whims
against some defendants and in favor of
others
but it didn't matter
the supreme court struck down federal
sentencing mandates in 2005 citing a
violation of the sixth amendment just
three years after marvin frankel's death
sentencing mandates were now just
suggested guidelines
and the variations in sentencing
came right back
so
in some ways the algorithms worked it
reduced extreme sentences some systemic
bias statistical noise and standard
deviations
and it also
failed badly with its robotic arbitrary
and sometimes nonsensical results that
flat out made some things
much much worse like messed up mandatory
minimum and determinate sentences
judges were happy to get their
professional discretion back
seventy-five percent preferred the new
system of using the guidelines as an
advisory tool while only three percent
preferred pure mandates
but
how does one human mind discern exactly
the right amount of punishment
if you steal something why isn't it
enough to just pay the person back
how fair is it that someone can take a
life yet only pay with 10 or 12 years of
their own to what exact degree does a
first time offender differ from a second
time offender from a 10th time offender
do we ever just give up on
rehabilitation
is a criminal responsible for the harm
he does to future generations
does an eye for an eye mean severe
retribution or just actually place a
limit on a fitting punishment
are there any crimes we should just
accept
should senile elderly people be
responsible for the crimes of their
youth
should we even have victimless crime
is the possibility of injustice the
price we have to pay for a chance at
perfect justice
are we trying to punish criminals
rehabilitate them separate them from
society a combination of all three if so
what's the proper balance of that and
how do we reduce conscious bias
unconscious variability and noise at a
national level that still allows for the
nuance of individual circumstances to be
addressed fairly city state and country
wide
what's the algorithm
to figure out all of that
what's the algorithm
for morality
what's the algorithm
[Music]
for justice
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you